hey you guys we're doing another movie
review
it's very interesting how i ended up
watching and reviewing this movie uh
this particular week
so this is a movie called stonehurst
asylum it came out back in 2014.
i don't remember how i first heard about
it but i think i saw it turn up on some
people's you know best horror movies of
the 2010s list or something like that
and it had like a really lot of uh big
british actors like actors that i liked
in it and it was sort of loosely based
on edgar allan poe story so it's just
kind of like oh i'll have to get around
to like watching that so i put it on my
very very long to watch list
but i hadn't gotten around to it yet
but then i was revisiting
a book review that i did uh this book
which i also bought completely randomly
like many many years ago called
enamorata by a guy named joseph gangemi
i'm not sure if i'm pronouncing that
correctly or gang gemmy
and i really really loved that book and
i was whatever for whatever reason i was
like revisiting um my review of it that
i did a while back
and when i was looking into the guy's
background i discovered that he was
actually uh you know in emirata was the
only novel that he wrote
but he was kind of better known for
writing screenplays one of which was
stonehurst asylum so i was kind of like
well [ __ ] i remember i had been wanting
to really see that movie
so now's uh the best time to go about
that it's on amazon prime i think it's
also on 2b for free if you want to watch
it on there now stonehurst asylum
even though it is based on an edgar
allen poe story sort of
which i'll get into in a little bit
it's not
necessarily a horror movie it does have
some kind of
hoary elements
but it's kind of more i don't know i
would call it more like a gothic
thriller
i see it compared a lot to shutter
island so if you liked that then you'll
probably
like this as well now this was actually
directed by brad anderson
who did the machinist he did session
nine
uh he did the sounds like episode of the
masters of horror series from back in
the 2000s so you know he's done a lot of
horror stuff but stuff that's kind of
like because i feel like the machinist
was not horror but it was like sort of
horror adjacent this one's kind of like
the same thing it's not necessarily like
scary but it does have kind of like
psychological uh thriller type aspect to
it and it's very very gothic in the
sense that it's set you know at the turn
of the 20th century and as i said it's
based on edgar allan poe story now the
post story that it's based on
is uh one of poe's lesser-known ones
which is called the system of dr tarr
and professor feather which is almost
like a black comedy or like a satire
it's like a satirical story the movie
doesn't really have a satirical tone to
it exactly
i have seen it called i was watching
like mark carmode's uh review of this
and he really really did not like it um
he thought that it was just like very
very what was the word he used over ripe
um
like everybody just like chewed the hell
out of the scenery which i guess they do
but it didn't really strike me
i don't know it really didn't strike me
as excessive i guess because i was going
into this expecting it to be like a
gothic sort of story like a melodrama so
it didn't really strike me that anyone
was like going way out of the thing and
like chewing all the scenery or anything
like that but apparently he did think
that and honestly this movie
even though as i said i first heard
about it because i saw it on somebody's
you know their favorite uh horror movies
of the 2010s list this really didn't get
that great of reviews it seemed like
most
of the reviews were just they said well
it wasn't like creepy enough or it
wasn't didn't go far enough like with
its uh satire
or you know or it just kind of like fell
flat it just wasn't good enough
but i don't know i just it's not like a
perfect movie but i actually found it
like pretty entertaining uh so your
mileage may vary like i said don't go
into it expecting it to be a horror
movie because it's not necessarily but
it does have that sort of like gothic
like that edgar allan poe sensibility
now as i said the story
the edgar allan poe story is actually
quite short and as i said it's more
satirical it's like a black comedy type
story because he did write funny [ __ ] as
well i don't know if a lot of people
know that because he's most known for
his horror stuff
but the story i mean the movie is pretty
much
uh you know like the first probably like
20 minutes or 30 minutes or something of
the movie is based on the story and then
it kind of just goes off in its own
direction
uh because you know it would be really
hard to make an entire movie out of the
story because it's so short now i will
say that this movie has
at least two pretty significant twists
and in order to talk about the movie at
all i'm probably gonna have to spoil the
first one the first twist is basically
the one that would have come at the end
of the edgar allen poe story and only
comes about 20 or 30 minutes into the
movie so it's not like i don't think
it's gonna ruin anybody's and honestly i
think
from what i could see of like the
trailer and some of the other things
like marketing materials about it they
didn't like outright spoil it but i
think even the poster like suggests the
twist at least the first one so i don't
feel too bad about spoiling it but i'm
not gonna spoil like the big twist at
the end because i did not see that
coming uh by any charge of the
imagination so i was just kind of like
oh wow all right maybe some people will
but
i didn't see it coming
so what we have i mean as i said this is
like an all-star cast listen to this
[ __ ] [ __ ] okay so kate beckinsale is
in this uh jim sturgis who was actually
in that wasn't he in across the universe
i need to watch that again that was a
great [ __ ] movie i saw that in the
theater michael kane is in this ben
kingsley is in this david thulis is in
this who i love i mean like every single
you know all these really really big uh
british
actors are in it so it's just an amazing
amazing stacked cast
so what we have this is set uh there's a
little bit of a prologue at the
beginning where it's just kind of like
this
you know sort of old school late 19th
century
uh you know medical thing where all
these medical students are in there
or they're they're gonna be an alienist
uh you know what we would call a
psychologist or psychiatrist nowadays
similar kind of thing
so there's a bunch of like medical
students and then
uh somebody's giving a lecture like a
doctor's giving a lecture and he brings
out kate beckinsale's character now her
character is named eliza graves which
actually was i think what the movie was
originally going to be called
so she comes out and uh the doctor's
just kind of like okay well this woman
has all the classic symptoms of female
hysteria
so
uh we've put we put her on heroin so
she's you know not gonna do anything
crazy or anything like that but he's
basically says well i'm going to
you know they don't use this word but
i'm essentially going to like trigger
her
uh into a reaction so you guys can see
what happens now you find out over the
course of the story that
whether or not eliza is
insane
uh i kind of doubt it but she does have
a thing where she can't really like if
somebody touches her like particularly
in a way like she can't do affection or
hugs or kisses or anything like that she
kind of like she freezes up now you find
out later that this is probably uh
because she was subjected to abuse
probably from her husband who she's
still married to um they actually ended
up putting her in asylum after
her husband apparently attacked her and
she defended herself by uh biting his
ear off and poking out one eye like i
said probably justifiably so but you
know this was 18.99 so of course they're
gonna stick her into asylum and say
she's crazy but she still has this thing
uh that's left over like i said anybody
that tries to touch her in any sort of
like affectionate way or any kind of
sexual or intimate way um she just like
freezes up in her hands like she starts
having uh seizures and things like that
so uh so that's kind of like the
prologue
and she is basically begging these
medical students she's like i'm not mad
i'm not mad please get me out of here
but obviously you know the doctor's like
of course they all say that you know
what i mean so then we skip ahead to uh
this other character edward newgate and
he's kind of like this young doctor
uh from oxford university and he is
traveling to this very remote asylum
called stonehurst asylum
and when he gets to the gate it's very
very like i said it's very gothic it's
like all up in the mountains and it's
just kind of like it's all foggy and it
has like this big wrought iron fence
it's great i love that kind of [ __ ]
so he turns up at the fence and david
thulis who's kind of like the
groundskeeper steward type of dude he
shows that he's like you know basically
who the [ __ ] are you and like so dr
negates go oh well i sent a letter to uh
the superintendent of the hospital it's
like i'm from oxford university and i
want to go into
you know i want to do asylum medicine
and i wondered if i could kind of like
follow him around on his rounds or
whatever
so they're like well we don't know if
you got a letter or not but whatever you
can like come inside
so he goes in and he meets the
superintendent dr silas lamb played by
ben kingsley
now when he gets there uh when newgate
gets there and silas lamb seems a little
bit weird but i mean not
overly weird or anything like that
and he's just kind of like okay well if
you uh you know wanna go into this line
of work or whatever it's like why don't
you come with me on my rounds and you
can see what we're doing here at
stonehurst
one thing that strikes uh dr newgate
right away is that this is not an asylum
the same kind of asylum that you would
normally see in victorian england in
1899 no one is running around naked in
the halls no one's in the cage no one's
in the cages nobody has straight jackets
on nobody's being like hosed or
anything like that
and basically the doctor's just kind of
like what is going on in here like
you're just letting them walk around
loose like regular ass people
and dr lam said yeah this is a new thing
that we're doing
uh we're essentially just letting them
live as though they're normal people
giving them some dignity like they will
give them little jobs to do
and things of that nature like he goes
to this one guy because this asylum it's
not it's actually for it's like a rich
people asylum he's basically like well
this is where like all the finest
families of europe this is where if you
have some embarrassing relatives that
has some mental illness this is where
they stick you so these are all just
kind of like actually dukes and lords
and things like that but have kind of
been shoved in there because they're an
embarrassment to their families like for
example there's one guy in there who i
think is some kind of duke or something
and he thinks that he's a horse
and so they basically like treat him as
though he's a horse like he gets groomed
and they feed him apples and stuff and
dr newgate is like well isn't that just
like you know i thought you're supposed
to be treating them you're just sort of
like
encouraging his delusion
and dr lam's like yeah that's what we're
doing we're encouraging their delusions
they can just do whatever they want to
and he's just like well you know
shouldn't you be trying to like cure
them or you know try to get them back
into society or whatever and he's like
why make he says something like why make
a miserable man out of a perfectly happy
horse he's like the guy's happy like
that so you know what's the big deal
so there's all of that going on
so dr newgate thinks this is weird but i
mean it does seem like the patients all
seem like pretty chill and like pretty
happy they just kind of like let them do
whatever crazy [ __ ] they want to do um
they let them eat with the staff it's
you know everybody just kind of like
hangs out together and it does seem to
be uh pretty effective like you know
nobody's acting crazy or nobody's no i
mean people are acting crazy but not
like danger is crazy everyone's just
kind of like hanging out and it seems
very chill and so dr negate's like huh
well this must be like some new kind of
method it's like maybe this is working
out it's maybe this is a good idea
so then he meets eliza graves who is the
woman that we saw
uh at the very beginning like at the
lecture uh who's played by kate
beckinsale now she is very very refined
she's kind of like an upper you know
kind of upper class lady whatever
and she's there like playing piano for
all the other inmates and she also has
this one
uh you know this is other woman who
works or is a nurse and she seems to
have like a very motherly or sisterly
relationship with that nurse and she
seems like a lovely person and edward
newgate is
smitten with her i kind of feel like
he's just like well she doesn't seem
crazy like maybe she's too beautiful to
be crazy i mean because she looks like
she has all her [ __ ] together you know
what i mean she's not like running
around jammies or anything like that she
has all her clothes and her hair is done
and everything like that so he's like i
just find it hard to believe that she's
uh she's crazy but he does think this
whole thing is like very very odd
so they have like this big dinner where
supposedly you know all the staff are
there at the table and like all of the
inmates are also there at the table
and uh it's kind of going okay until
edward sort of gets on the wrong side of
david thulis's character whose name is
mickey finn uh and actually that's how
he gets on the wrong side by making fun
of his name because he's like oh like
slipping someone at mickey finn that's
pretty hilarious and uh you know so
there's like all this tension all of a
sudden
and uh so what ends up happening then is
that
mickey finn
says you know they they kind of have a
little bit of back and forth like i said
there's this kind of like all this
tension and argument and stuff and then
he's like oh you know it's it's all
right it's you know it's i was just
being funny he's like here let's have a
drink to our friendship
so he doesn't really want to drink it
because he kind of suspects that
something might be going wrong but he's
like well everybody's looking at me and
i kind of have to
but then uh eliza kate beckinsale's
character like kicks him from under the
table so the drink spills
and then she's going kind of like oh my
god you know i'll take you in the
kitchen and like clean you up and stuff
so she takes him in there and she's like
you have to get the [ __ ] out of here
like right now and he's just like why
she's like i can't tell you just go it's
just like just please listen to me you
know you just get the [ __ ] out of here
and he's like well i don't really want
to go with that you know it's like what
the hell
you won't tell me what's going on
but she won't she's just like just get
the [ __ ] out don't you know and don't
look back so you're just kind of like
huh intriguing
so he doesn't leave it's he kind of
stays over and then he starts hearing
some weird noise like coming through his
vents and stuff like that like from down
in the basement and like i said at this
point this is kind of like the first
twist
and as i said if you've read the edgar
allen post story and you might have
surmised it you know so so this is kind
of like a spoiler alert but like i said
i'm not going to spoil like the last
twist but this it's kind of hard to talk
about the movie without spoiling this
first twist
so the first twist being he hears all
this noise
and he makes his way trying to figure
out where this noise is coming from and
he goes down to the basement
and down in the basement is a whole
bunch of people in cages including
michael caine and a bunch of other
people
and michael caine tells him hey
i'm actually the superintendent of this
hospital and this is all the staff like
that's the head nurse and that's the
groundskeeper and that's uh the
essentially the lunatics have taken over
the asylum uh dr silas lamb was a
patient
and uh he
staged a coup essentially
and uh overthrew the staff and they
basically drugged all of them and then
locked them all down in the basement
because they were uh they said taking
revenge
for all of the
methods that dr salt who is uh michael
caine's character were using against the
patients and this is where the movie
sets up are really interesting and i
kind of feel like this is maybe why a
lot of critics didn't love this movie
because they said they kind of wish that
it had gone more into this moral dilemma
which i agree it does go into it a
little bit but it maybe could have
explored it a little bit more
because here's the thing
uh even though the the hospital is now
being run by the patients
uh and all of the actual staff uh you
know the medical professionals are
locked up down in the basement
the patients were making the argument
that uh the methods being used to treat
the mentally ill in 1899
were obviously pretty barbaric by
today's standards they would and
particularly dr salt in this movie
he's kind of like his whole thing is
like well to cure somebody of mental
illness you have to find what their
greatest fear is and like keep exposing
them to it so they were doing stuff like
you know uh i don't know they just like
had these things where they'd spin them
around and like pour like water like
essentially like kind of waterboarding
them and all this other kind of stuff so
and they had them all locked up in cages
and whatnot so
it's kind of interesting as i said they
do kind of skirt around this that
you know were the patients
justified
in doing what they did because the way
they were being treated was so barbaric
from their point of view
now
the way that it's being run now with
silas lamb running it but in some ways
it's better but in some ways it's really
not because silas lamb is kind of a
dangerous i don't know if i'd call him a
psychopath but he's not you know he he's
not real he's not right you know what
i'm saying
but the thing about it is that his whole
ideas
that he had about treating the mental
ill mentally ill patients yes you're
kind of letting them buy into their own
delusions and we're all just pretending
that this guy's a horse or whatever
because he's like well that makes them
happy and that keeps them pacified and
why isn't that better why should we try
to make them normal just because they're
embarrassing to their families or
whatever um why don't you just like let
them be
and he's like and i gave them
jobs around like the one girl that was a
nurse was actually not a nurse she was a
patient and but she was had her [ __ ]
together enough that she could act as a
nurse so she helped to take care of the
other patients so the ones that were
more capable were kind of given jobs and
were taking care of the ones that were
less capable and it mostly seemed to be
working out i mean some cracks were
appearing around the edges because
they were like well we don't have as
many provisions as we did um you know
it's over the winter time and it's like
what happens when spring comes and like
visitors come back and they're gonna
figure out what happened and they're
gonna take all the money away and [ __ ]
like that so there you know there there
were
hints that it was kind of falling apart
a little bit
but overall the patients did seem to be
happier now as the story was going on
though
silas lamb started losing more and more
of his [ __ ] and then started doing
some more barbaric stuff like electro
like you know electrocuting people in
their brains and stuff doing stuff that
more resembled
uh you know what dr salt was doing the
the methods that he so hated so as i
said that was kind of like a really
interesting moral conundrum that i kind
of feel like they maybe could have
explored more but i mean that wasn't
really i don't know like i said this was
just kind of like a straight like gothic
psychological thriller and it does go
into those issues but not super super
deeply but i just really did like that
that sort of conundrum was introduced
because i was just kind of like oh well
you know maybe
you could kind of see like that the
patients had a point and also that like
the doctors had a point too because all
the the doctors like uh michael caine
and stuff like that they weren't
necessarily portrayed as monsters or
uh or anything like that like michael
caine was kind of a dick but like the
other one like the head nurse and stuff
like that seemed like a lovely very
sympathetic person so the all of the um
staff the original staff at the hospital
that the patients had put down in the
cages i mean some of them were you know
perfectly nice people who probably
didn't victimize the patients in the
same way so i just kind of feel like it
was uh interesting how they sort of
presented the
that conundrum there and like i said
they could have gone into it a little
bit deeper but they didn't but you know
that's that's what you're gonna do so
yeah so at that point
it gets to be i felt like um well i
really did like this movie quite a bit
although i did think that like the
middle part of it like sagged a little
bit because once
once dr newgate uh finds
you know all the other staff like down
in the basement
and he's uh you know gonna try and get
them out
but he doesn't want dr silas lamb
because they say look dr lam he's
dangerous you know what i mean uh you
know he was kind of one of our worst
patients
and he's like so i don't really want
them to
figure out what i'm doing because then
they'll throw my ass down here which
they totally would so like i said
they're not like better than the ones
than the original staff because if you
disagree with what they were doing they
would also give you shock therapy or
they would throw you down in the cage
too
so it's not like they were that much
more enlightened or anything like that
so in the middle part he's trying to get
trying to figure out a way that he can
get the original staff out or like uh
you know so they can escape and how he
can get like eliza out of there because
he's subsequently of course fallen in
love with her and she doesn't really
want to go and the thing that like
freaks him out is that she knew about i
mean obviously because she was one of
the patients um and she was maybe one of
the ones that encouraged dr silas lammer
helped him uh to put the original staff
in the thing because they were
you know doing horrible stuff to her
because like i said she had that
hysteria thing quote unquote where she
couldn't be touched and
it would cause all of these problems and
it seemed like they were
dr salt or whoever were like
deliberately like touching her
inappropriately like to get her over
her fear you know what i mean because
that's kind of his whole method so she
was all in uh with the patients taking
over the asylum because she was like
they treated us horribly before so there
was that whole thing so she doesn't
really want to leave too because she
says well i belong here i'm insane uh so
you know i don't really need to be
running around loose and also it's
implied too that her husband if she gets
out and goes back with him then he will
continue to abuse her so she feels safer
in the hospital than she does at home
with her husband so she does not want to
leave
so
so then like so the middle part is just
kind of like all new gate trying to
figure out how we gonna get these people
out of here how am i gonna get eliza out
of here how am i not gonna get my own
ass killed uh you know when silas lamb
and mickey finn like figure out what
he's doing that he's like working
against them and there's all this other
kind of stuff and then like i said it
kind of goes on like that and then it
builds up to like this other big twist
at the end which i will not spoil but
yeah this is um this was like pretty
decent it was better than i was
expecting it has a [ __ ] great cast as
i said i kind of feel like
i kind of feel like a lot of the reviews
were either really really kind of like
meh or
you know oh this could have been you
know it's good but it could have been a
lot better
um you know it could have been better
but honestly
i didn't really see why it got such bad
reviews really um and like i said i
don't think the reviews were bad
necessarily it's that like a lot of
people just thought it was sort of
lackluster um i didn't find that i found
it pretty entertaining as i said i
didn't think it was as overwrought as
like sip like mark kermode said that it
was like he just thought everybody was
like chewing scenery and i said it
wasn't that bad uh yeah it was had a
little bit of melodrama
but it's gothic it's a gothic story so
that didn't really bother me it didn't
really strike me as being like
really over the top or campy or anything
like that i thought it was like
perfectly fine
so i don't know so like i said your
mileage may vary if you want to see
a decent adaptation of a kind of a
lesser known pose story that is not
really straight up horror
but has like a really cool like gothic
sensibility to it and treads a little
bit into
you know mental illness the way it was
treated the way it was looked upon at
the turn of the 20th century uh this is
actually like a pretty interesting
film to watch and i really liked like
the whole atmosphere of it it just had
like a really cool like hammer-esque
kind of look to it which i thought was
really cool and as i said all the you
know the cast is great it was just like
it was just a fun fun time so yeah this
is on amazon prime i believe uh so if
you have amazon prime uh subscription i
think you can watch it for free and i
think it's also on to be at least as of
this recording so you can watch it for
free on there as well so let me know if
you've seen this because i feel like a
lot of people don't talk about it all
that much um came out in 2014 and i
don't even remember hearing about it
back then but i only heard about it like
years later
but i'd be curious to know if anybody
had seen it or what they thought about
it so let me know in the comments and
that will do it for this flickers of
fear i will see you guys on the next one
bye